alrighty so as i say there are people
who want to control you they want to
control your right to see information
they would also love to control how you
raise your kids there's a piece
in the washington post it was retweeted
by the american federation of teachers
head randy weingarten who's one of the
worst people in america i mean her her
absolute
scorn for the parents of america is
truly astonishing
okay she retweeted this piece the piece
is titled quote parents claim they have
the right to shape their kids school
curriculum
they don't um yeah we do actually
it's written by jack schneider an
assistant professor of education at the
university of massachusetts lowell and
jennifer berkshire a freelance
journalist and co-author of a wolf at
the schoolhouse door the dismantling of
public education and the future of
school
and the idea is that only school boards
only government actors only the wise
will determine how your children are to
be educated now what's kind of amazing
about this is that the rise of the
public education system in america if
you actually look back historically was
not particularly a bad thing but it also
was kind of an anti-catholic thing if
you look at how public schools were
supposed to
operate they were almost designed to
operate as anti-catholic indoctrination
centers and people talk pretty openly
about this at the time so from the very
beginning there's been open debate about
how kids are to be taught in schools and
whether schools are simply supposed to
convey reading writing and arithmetic or
whether they're supposed to impose
values
but parents have always had the ability
to take their kids out of school to
homeschool their kids but the left would
like this not to be the case
i recently did a discussion slash debate
with anna kasparian of the young turks
and she openly said that she would love
the finnish model in which there are no
private schools and homeschooling is
forboden
in which basically you must send your
kids to a government indoctrination
center
well that's the underlying case here in
the washington post
quote in their search for issues that
will deliver congress in 2022
conservatives have begun to circle
around the cause of quote unquote
parents rights in indiana republican
attorney general todd rokita recently
introduced a parent's bill of rights
which asserts that education policy and
curriculum should actually accurately
reflect the values of indiana families
in le in florida the legislature passed
an even more comprehensive bill assuring
that the state and its public schools
cannot infringe on the fundamental
rights of parents
given this frenzy one might reasonably
conclude that radicals are out to
curtail the established rights that
americans have over the educational
sphere yet what's actually radical here
is the assertion of parental powers that
have never previously existed
this is not to say that parents should
have no influence over how their
children are taught a common law and
case law in the united states have long
supported the idea that education should
prepare young people to think for
themselves even if that runs counter to
the wishes of parents in the words of
legal scholar jeff shulman this effort
may well divide child from parent not
because socialist educators want to
indoctrinate children but because
learning to think for oneself is what
children do except that's not what
you're talking about it's not about
children learning to think for
themselves it's about parents wanting
their kids to have their values and to
pass their values on to their kids it's
literally my number one priority in life
and about educators who have a different
set of values this is not a value
neutral proposition
okay which is the reason why i pick
where my kids go to school and i
specifically
ask the principals where my kids go to
school if my kids are being taught
values that i agree with and i will not
send my kids to a school or the values
that i agree with are not taught
when do the interests of parents and
children diverge according to these
columnists
generally it occurs when a parent's
desire to inculcate a particular
worldview denies the child exposure to
other ideas and values that an
independent young person might wish to
embrace or at least entertain
to turn over all decisions to parents
then would risk inhibiting the ability
of young people to think independently
as the political scientist rob reich has
argued quote minimal autonomy requires
especially for its civic importance that
a child be able to examine his or her
own political values and beliefs and
those of others with a critical eye if
we value that and the structure of
schooling cannot simply replicate in
every particularity the values and
beliefs of a child's home
the law has long reflected this consider
homeschooling although it is legal
across the country states still regulate
its practice such regulations aren't
often enforced but they are certainly on
the books homeschooling parents can be
required to establish minimal minimal
academic qualifications to submit
examples of student work to school
district administrators or even to adopt
a state-approved curriculum
the sudden push for parental rights then
isn't a response to substantive changes
in education or the law it's a political
tactic
and then they say that it's a paranoid
style of politics quoting richard
hofstadter one of the most overrated
historians of the 20th century talking
about how it's just paranoid to think
that these people want to indoctrinate
your kids they have no political values
they just want you to have kids who
challenge everything that you believe
in framing our public schools as
extremist organizations that undermine
the prerogatives of families
conservatives are bringing napoleon to
the fight that may rally the base and
tilt a few elections in their favor but
as with any scorched earth campaign the
cost of this conflict will be born long
after the fighting stops parents may end
up with a new set of rights only to
discover they have lost something even
more fundamental in the process turned
against their schools and their
democracy they may wake up from their
conspiratorial fantasies to find a pile
of rubble and a heap of ashes this was
retweeted again by the american
federation of teacher's head
but you shouldn't worry about the fact
that they are teaching your kid radical
crap in school
and the school library is filled with
pornography which is actually the case
in loudoun county for example no what
what you should actually
worry about is your own authoritarian
fascism in wanting your kids to be
inculcated with your values
okay so the plan is to hijack your kids
i mean they're openly saying that the
plan is to hijack your kids and that you
really should have no say in the matter
i mean it makes sense on a sort of
demographic level right there's one
group in the united states that is
having lots of kids namely religious
parents there's another group that is
having almost no kids namely highly
secularized parents and highly secular
people in the united states are having
very very few children at this point and
people who are religious are having lots
of kids which means that down the line
if parents actually teach their kids
their values and those kids live with
those values you're going to get a more
right-wing more religious country life
doesn't like that very much so one of
those solutions is take those kids and
indoctrinate them in your ideas
put them in government indoctrination
factories and churn out good little
liberals
and then tell parents they have no
rights because after all you're just
teaching them how to think you're just
teaching them to be broad-minded and
open-minded and to challenge parental
authority but if your authority is
challenged in any way then it's really
bad and by the way we know this is the
case whether it comes from parents or
whether it comes from students you know
how many letters i receive from public
school students who say i'm afraid to
speak up in class because my teacher is
going to punish me if i disagree with
the teacher don't give me that high
school teachers are teaching children
how to think in the main they're
teaching their own opinions very often
and where you send your kid is going to
determine what opinions are taught it is
that simple but again the idea here is
the institutions must be upheld and if
that means curbing first amendment
rights fine if it means curbing parental
rights absolutely
the left is simply willing to do this
and standing up is key at this point
they also of course would like to
curtail economic rights as well which is
why they are now pushing an
unconstitutional wealth tax by the way
it is unconstitutional when you hear the
democrats are trying to tax unrealized
gains at the federal level there's
nothing in the constitution that allows
for this
right the the article 1 section 9 of the
constitution of the united states
does not allow for this sort of taxation
which is why you had to have a
constitutional amendment that
constitutional amendment to allow the
income tax only allows the income tax
it does not allow direct taxation of
unrealized gains
but democrats are pushing this because
again economic control ideological
control control over your kids education
do you ever did ever heard of these
people that um maybe we don't want to be
controlled maybe the entire premise of
american liberty is that we are not
controlled and we get to make our own
decisions
and then when you maximize the control
of morons over every aspect of your life
your life gets materially worse i've
been talking a lot in in recent days
about risk and risk allocation about the
fact that human beings tend to want to
minimize risk we don't like risk at the
very least at the very least we don't
like loss
right
and so what we are prone to is handing
over authority to people who pledge that
they are going to minimize our risk but
here's the thing this is what the
institutions are learning and we learn
it anew every time there's a major
unexpected recession for example
you can push off risk you can pretend
that reality entails no risk you can
empower experts to minimize risk but all
they can do is build dams against risk
the waters of risk do not go away
the best way to deal with the endemic
risk in life is to incentivize people to
make good individual decisions in terms
of how to mitigate risk
and maybe local level decisions on how
to deal with risks if they materialize
but when you pledge that you can stop
all risk from happening when you pledge
that if you give somebody complete
informational control they will make
your life better or you give people
complete control over your kids they
will make your life better and your
kid's life better
all you're doing is building a dam that
holds back the waters of risk and when
that dam collapses
there is a tsunami not a trickle of risk
that is handleable not a stream of risk
that you can tranch off or that you can
redirect or that you can use to power
your economy instead you create a
damned up flood of risk
and when that damn bursts the risk
overwhelms the entire civilization
and that is what is happening right now
the institutions are cracking those
institutions were damn meant to prevent
you from exercising your freedom to
assess risk and now as that damn bursts
they're desperately trying to shore it
up by more control it's not going to
work
they'd be better off lessening the power
of the water behind the dam by allowing
us to actually make individual
assessments about things that matter to
us by allowing us to speak freely and
access information freely by allowing us
to educate our kids as we see fit but
they're not going to do that because to
do that would
in fact undermine their entire project
which is the control whether they
believe it or not
whether they believe that they are
making your life better if you give them
more control or whether they just want
the power is irrelevant
the effect is that they are going to
control every aspect of your life from
soup to nuts if they have the chance and
they're openly bragging about i mean the
new york times is talking about joe
biden creating cradle to grave welfare
programs the phrase cradle to grave used
to be a pejorative in american politics
it was something the republicans said
about democrats that they wanted cradle
to grave care demonstrating that they
were innovating the american public now
it's used as a piece of braggadocio by
the left
the agenda is pretty much out there in
the open which means that we have the
obligation to fight that agenda
it's the reason why it is so necessary
to look at what big cities like chicago
are doing right now in implementing
universal basic income and say to
yourself what is this designed to do
except to make people more dependent on
government
except except to continue to foster the
lie that the more control you give these
people the safer they will keep you
they're not going to keep you safe at
all because eventually reality always
intervenes and when it does it gets
really really ugly
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed